need motivation watch the top table
believe nation hey it's Evan Carmichael
and this channel was designed to help
you overcome the number one challenge
that is holding you back a lack of
belief in yourself so get ready for some
success focused ideas from Tim Ferriss
to give you the confidence motivation
and belief that you need okay let's kick
it off with rule number one have other
interests a diversified identity in some
fashion I think this is important so
that your self-worth isn't only
associated with your startup that's
probably a controversial recommendation
what that means is you should actually
spend time involved with other skills so
in San Francisco for instance many
startup founders I know who are very
efficient and effective of their startup
rock climbing they get outside they do a
few things so that if one goes well they
can they can remain optimistic each week
which is very difficult if you're only
directed at your startup rule number two
focus on your strengths I only invest in
things that I understand and things that
I use or would use myself this is really
really really important anytime I step
outside of that is usually when the
universe kicks me in the nuts really
hard and I lose my money I think it's
it's critical to as an entrepreneur
scratch your own itch it increases the
odds of success or the probability of
success and then it's as an investor I
look for people who are scratching their
own - rule number three pick the right
things to do and you're thinking about a
product launch
first thing I would ask is is it the
right time to do product launch so if
your product isn't figured out if you
can't hold the orders now is not the
right time to be on TechCrunch in my
opinion or in any other major media
outlet once you're in a major media
outlet they're not going to cover you
again for some period of time or ever if
you're in the business section the New
York Times they're not going to cover
you four weeks later when your product
is better and you're ready so make sure
that you pick your timing a few things
so there's paid exposure and unpaid
exposure I like to focus on unpaid
because it makes you it forces you to
make better decisions in the beginning
so I would read as I always say the 22
immutable laws of marketing 1,000 true
fans written by Kevin Kelly I would also
read best-selling book PR and publicity
I think it is by Rick Frischmann Fri SH
ma n all the techniques apply to more
than books and learn to tell the story
what are you focusing on are you using
yourself to tell the story and then the
product is associated is it a trend
piece are you trying to tie what you're
doing into a greater trend or just very
effective way of getting media in which
case you're gonna need other examples so
you need to get comfortable bringing in
sort of cooperative competitors to
create that trend base learn the art of
the pitch and of messaging only once you
have figured that out what I say then
you go out and you pay to acquire people
because now if your messaging is off
it's costing you money rule number four
have a focused metric you need to know
what your unique strengths are and be
willing to delegate so I would say that
the question of whether you should take
a skill learn it yourself delegated
someone else or hire a new team member
are determined by having a very accurate
self assessment and assessment number
your team skills not only what you can
do but what you should be doing that's
very important so if you're a startup
CEO or founder
a team of say two to ten people as soon
as you have funds to hire you should not
be focused on the things that you are
bad at sounds very very intuitive but
it's not because you might have enough
time to do those things but the question
is do you have the attention to dedicate
to this thing so they're not an
interruption especially if you are
venture-backed startup and you're
competing against other companies that
also have a lot of funding the game the
game and the race goes to the Swift so
you have to have you have to have a lot
of velocity also if you want more
confidence check on my 254 series it's
free the link to join is in the
description below a lot of the anxiety
that we feel is actually due to using
words that are not defined very well in
fact I think you should ask yourself
first and foremost why do you create
content self-love is not an indulgence
it's not a nice-to-have it is a
prerequisite rule number five scratch
your own itch you need to be able to
sell whether it's Kickstarter whether
it's near times whether it's your local
newspaper you need to be able to
communicate effectively and so which is
why when entrepreneurs ask me for books
to read outside of business books I say
on writing well bird by bird all books
on writing improving communication David
Ogilvy Ogilvy on advertising study print
ads where you have very little space I
think those are all very very effective
the best entrepreneurs I've ever met are
all good communicators it's the one
perhaps one of the very few unifying
factors they're exceptional
communicators practice is the only way
to get better at communicating and
practicing speaking does not provide you
generally with something to review later
which is why the written word is so
powerful writing is thought crystallized
on a piece of paper that can then be
reviewed it's very difficult to do that
with speech which is why I recommend
people focus on honing their skills in
writing
and take time to study good direct
response ads take time to for instance
maybe develop a swipe file so one of the
things that I did four years is any time
I bought something I would identify the
ad the phone call the print ad the the
offer whatever it was that made me
decide to buy it and I would either cut
it out or record it put it into Evernote
whatever it might be and save it so I
had a record of everything that I bought
and why I bought it and then I could go
back and review it and I'd be like oh
looks like I fell for this this and this
not a bad way it looks like this tipped
me from or not interested - yeah I'll
spend five fifty five hundred five
thousand dollars on that yeah I save all
that everything that works in sales has
been done already you do not need to
reinvent the wheel so just keep track of
the crap that you buy or the awesome
stuff that you buy and decide you know
what was the trigger what push me over
the edge and then just sell the people
like you that's what I do it's really
easy
people are like who's your market I'm
like well you know I'm a 30-something
that set based tech-savvy email so why
don't I just solve those people it's a
lot easier than trying to guess rule
number six ideas are worth noting ideas
are worth noting I mean ideas are really
they're not a dime a dozen that are just
nothing all the good founders I know
even the bad founders can come up with
ideas all day long it doesn't mean
anything you have to be able to execute
and you know one of the sort of Maxim's
that I was told once was you know your
success will be measured in the number
of uncomfortable conversations you're
willing to have so I haven't get asked
if an entrepreneur should say start a
business based on one of their passions
or if they should find the most
attractive market opportunity and build
a business out of that whether they like
it or not I don't think it's either/or I
think you need both I would say look
here and credit card statement identify
where you spend an unusual percentage of
your income where are you price
insensitive then how old are you what
gender are you where do you live and
design a product that has all of those
things intersecting rule number seven
learn the art of the pitch it's very
easy to be seduced by doing things
efficiently trying to do a lot of things
well I don't believe that's the most
important thing the most important thing
is picking the right things to do in the
first place
and that's being effective versus just
being efficient so within a start-up its
success I don't think it's measured by
how many things you can do at once it's
measured by how effectively you're able
to pick the one or two things into the
highest priority and there's always
going to be a seduction to get
distracted and focus on 20 things at
once and the most effective
entrepreneurs I know are very good at
focusing on one or two things and either
eliminating the rest delegating to other
people or outsourcing it so it's not
done within the team but it's actually
two third parties rule number eight be
able to sell first entrepreneurs tend to
miscalculate is everything what I mean
by that is
[Music]
optimism has a place but I think even
more so for the first time entrepreneur
you need to be pragmatically pessimistic
what I mean by that is you need to
define all the worst-case scenarios in
terms of financial loss time loss etc
look at what you will learn if that
happens and accept and come to terms
with that before you ever start if you
don't do that and you go straight into
battling the world trying to conquer the
world with rose-colored glasses on the
first time you hit a major hiccup you're
gonna become really demoralized and you
will quit so optimism all that rah rah
rah that's awesome but you need to hope
for the best and prepare for the worst
before you ever get started I always
recommend that rule number nine be
pragmatically pessimistic I think it's
important to have at least one or two
numbers that you strike on a weekly
basis so that could be for web-based
properties or services or products it
could be weekly average uniques what it
is doesn't matter that much but matters
less than having a metric that you try
to improve every week you can have one
or two of them you really shouldn't have
many more than that I don't think could
be conversion from sign up to let's say
first stage of sign up to completion of
sign up there are many different metrics
that you can use but you I think that to
keep the team focused especially in the
small company it's very important to
have one or two the folks on a weekly
basis rule number ten use failure to
help you I think failure would be a big
piece even though I view failure
differently than I think many people I
view it as a feedback mechanism but if
you look at even let's say the 4-hour
workweek didn't start off called the
4-hour workweek it was also turned down
by 26 out of twenty-seven publishers and
hopefully pretty soon it'll be
celebrating four years unbroken on the
New York Times bestseller list and I
like to whenever possible illustrate
those failures because people will
everyone will face failure or from
mistakes and those are the divergent
points from which they can either go in
a good direction or a bad direction and
I want to illustrate that oftentimes the
finish line is only a hot
feet from where you stand but it might
seem that it's a hundred miles away rule
number 11 ask great questions I find
that levels of success in almost any
industry or area correlate to a person
asking great questions in some cases
they seem absurd in fact the hallmarking
way of great questions is that sound
completely ridiculous so someone might
ask why peter thiel why can't you
achieve your ten year goals in the next
six months there's a thought exercise
that's a that's that's a good question
to answer for yourself and these types
of questions come up surprisingly often
with with very very impressive folks
whether it's in business military
entertainment or otherwise and the way
you can get better at questions is by
studying interviews in part so I studied
Larry King
I studied Charlie Rose I studied Terry
Gross I studied that that go down the
list
I studied Tony Robbins who does
in-person one-on-one interventions at
his events in front of ten thousand five
thousand people and he's just genius
with how he uses questions to like
pattern interrupt and grab someone's
attention and divert them in a more
productive productive direction now why
is that relevant relevant because
thinking is the process of asking
questions you're asking yourself
questions and then you're answering them
in your own head so if you get better at
asking other people questions you get
better at asking yourself questions
which means you are a you're improving
your thought performance and level of
thinking rule number 12 starts small
when I'm procrastinating because there
is indecision and this is a particularly
dove procrastination in other words if I
have 10 things on my to-do list or 10
potential projects I could pursue what
to do in that situation and what I ask
myself is which one of these if done
will make the rest irrelevant or easier
this is a key question I ask all the
time which one of these will make all
the rest easier to do if done first or
all the rest I'm irrelevant don't even
need to do them that is how I will then
hone in on one piece of the puzzle and
this can be applied all over the
but let's just say it's the double the
podcast it could be losing weight all
right you can see that's very very
amorphous we need time lines we need an
amount to lose and then you wanna make
it as small as possible so give you a
different example if you look if you
want to start flossing your teeth
who likes flossing their teeth pretty
much nobody so how do you start flossing
your teeth well you want to make it as
easy as possible to develop it as part
of your routine to make it as automatic
as anything else that you do
consistently and you could borrow from
say BJ Fogg who's done a lot of research
at Stanford and elsewhere make it as
small as possible meaning in the
beginning do less than you are capable
of doing so this is another key when you
think something is too big or onerous so
it's too intimidating or it's too much
of a pain in the ass
all right so for flossing you might say
I'm only gonna floss my front two teeth
that's three gaps that's all you're
gonna do and you want to make it again
as easy as possible so you might use a
Waterpik or you might use those
disposable flossing gadgets so you don't
have to do you know tourniquets on your
fingers which is also one of the side
effects of flossing that deters people
make it as easy as possible now this
applies to a lot more than flossing so
I've talked to many of the people for
sake tools of Titan's people who are
eighth time New York Times bestselling
authors or prolific musicians prolific
music producers like Rick Rubin who is
legendary and it all comes down to tiny
homework assignments so Rick if he has a
stuck artist for instance he will say
can you get me one word or one line that
you might like for this song that you're
working on by tomorrow is that possible
many many homework assignments all right
so with the creative project in the
beginning that's one it's related to a
piece of advice that I got from Neil
Strauss eight-time New York Times
bestselling author he's written for the
New York Times is written for the
rolling for Rolling Stone magazine and
that is lower your standards so he
doesn't believe in writer's block he
says your standards are just too high
you're creating performance anxiety for
yourself so the advice that I got from
another writer which matches with that
is
two crappy pages per day so a lot of
people are like I'm gonna kill it I need
an ambitious goal let me do 1500 words
2,000 words per day for this book I'm
working on well there's a very high
probability that you're gonna fall short
of that and then you will get
demoralized then you will get
intimidated by the task and then you
will start procrastinating so make the
hurdle make the success threshold really
really low that's what I've done for my
last three books is two crappy pages per
day that's all I need if I don't end up
using them that's fine I just need to
get out to crappy pages what ends up
happening with the flossing with the
writing with say exercise if you're
gonna exercise you're making a new
year's resolution don't make it in the
hour a day four times a week no no no no
no ten and you if you don't have an
exercise habit five to ten minutes at
the gym three times a week plenty and in
all those cases you will feel successful
because you've checked your box for
success and then very often you will
exceed that for extra credit right okay
well I'm already at the gym I'll go for
an extra 10 minutes well I'm already
flossing my teeth we'll do an extra four
well I've already hit my two pages but
I'm feeling great and I'm in the flow
maybe I'll do 10 maybe I'll do 20 but it
prevents you from feeling like a failure
this is very very important that is what
do you rails a lot of people and it also
makes the task less intimidating rule
number 13 be focused it's easy to
discard say 10 terrible ideas and go
after the one good idea but when you
start to get a little bit of momentum
you can drown yourself in good
opportunities that aren't great
opportunities and if you scatter your
focus you try to do 17 different product
lines you can kill your business really
easily particularly when you have a
small team so I think asking yourself
repeatedly what is the one project the
one initiative the one campaign that if
successful will render the rest of these
things either unnecessary or much much
easier what is that what is that one
step and you know I've called that this
lead Domino before but what is the one
thing on this list of seven different
campaigns that will make all the other
ones are relevant or much easy how do
you
I mean that's a tough answer isn't it
because they all sound good yeah I think
they can and I think that what it comes
down to often times is it returns back
to measurements so how are we defining
success like if we want to grow the
company let's just say what does that
mean in three months six months what are
we measuring why are we measuring those
things and you know what is a sort of a
comfort goal meaning like okay we think
we can easily hit this number what is a
stretch and what is like Oh hallelujah
we've we threaded a needle and and then
come up with a really concrete number to
tackle and once you have that number
then you can look at those five and say
all right which of those are going to
serve us right now and I'm dealing with
that increasingly so because I have all
these different branches of content and
activities and angel investing and so on
it's very easy for me to get scattered
it's never been easier so I have to
continually ask that type of question
what's your main focus now if you had a
boil it down to one my main focus right
now is building the pod cat building my
podcasts in fair show up to a point
where it's consistently in the top ten
to fifteen on iTunes so that I can
establish a presence and name
recognition in Hollywood and
entertainment which I can leverage then
for the TV show and film projects that
I'll be expanding into in the next three
to nine months and specifically what
that means is targeted advertising for
the podcast specifically towards people
who are producers agents actors
directors in Hollywood in New York City
all of that can be quantified rule
number 14 unplug and reset the four hour
work week is possible but you need to
completely unplug and reset and the
reason that's necessary is because
there's an epidemic and I do mean
epidemic in this country of information
abuse and information addiction where
people have come to believe that
checking email 200 times per day having
a blackberry to your head or in your
hand while you're at dinner or on the
subway or in your car or with your
friends
is the path to becoming more productive
and more successful I mean it isn't it
isn't because giving everyone around you
every person in the world immediate
access to you is inviting interruption
and inviting minutiae to completely
invade your life which is happening to
everyone yeah it did happen to me I had
no intention of writing this book but
from 2000 to 2004 I was working at
startups in Silicon Valley I started my
own I was CEO and I worked from 7:00
a.m. to 9:00 p.m. every day I checked
Outlook hitting send receive 100 to 200
times per day like a rat with a cocaine
pellet dispenser slept under my cubicle
sent emails on Thanksgiving to prospects
it was the depressing scene and it's a
very unfortunately common scene and I
think everyone is at a point of
overwhelmed there is more information
than we can possibly organize time
management is dead the way turnaround is
you have to completely unplug and reset
that means you need to take a step back
forget about what people expect you to
do forget about what's popular and
really look at what works and what is
consuming your time so there are four
steps
there's definition elimination
automation and liberation definition is
simple first need to define your ideal
lifestyle what do you want to be doing
from when you wake up to when you go to
sleep and so what do you want to have
what do you want to be what you want to
do and how much does that ideal
lifestyle cost and that becomes your
target elimination is simple it's
getting rid of everything all the static
all the noise all the interruptions of
the micromanaging all the people
possible that interfere with getting you
to that ideal lifestyle the third
automation is about taking the few
remaining tasks that are important the
time-consuming and either delegating
automating or somehow outsourcing them
so in my particular case I have an army
of MBAs in India about 25 of them who
work for $4 an hour and take care of
tasks that otherwise consume hundreds of
my hours and then the last step
liberation is about the final ingredient
in lifestyle design which is mobility
and then also how to use the time once
you create it which is very difficult
for most people okay this is fascinating
but that's the point it is difficult to
mean how do you put the BlackBerry down
how aren't you worried that you're not
going to make as much money that you're
going to lose clients do you have
statistics that show that that's not the
case
I have statistics that would absolutely
make your head spin so if you're
interrupted by email and phone there was
an experiment done at Kings King's
College for example that showed that
people who were stoned scored six points
better on likeyou tests and people were
interrupted by email and phone and that
good to know 26% of people in the
American workforce are on the verge of a
nervous breakdown the system is not
working so it's not a question of if I
should do this this question of when it
is the only real alternative so one
simple step then people can take a baby
step to prove the concept is to simply
use an autoresponder set up an
autoresponder that tells everyone who
emails you I will be checking email
twice a day at 11:00 and 4:00 p.m. if
you require a more urgent response
before one of those two times call me on
my cell phone okay if I start losing
customers I'm gonna call you too you can
call me okay what's going to happen
instead of losing customers you'll get
more done in the next 48 hours and you
would in the next two weeks
rule number 15 accept the collateral
damage in a world where people expect
immediate responses often times and
increasingly so you have to I believe
let small bad things happen constantly
to have any agenda of your own and to
get the big positive things done so it's
it's recognizing that to prevent all her
feelings all mistakes all problems all
of this is impossible and if you try to
do that you'll never have a proactive
schedule of your own is extremely
important so effectively just saying I'm
going to accept the collateral damage
and believe that what I'm embarking upon
is worth more than those minor or
reversible problems and then forging
ahead
that you got to take a few flesh wounds
rule number 16 try the five minute
journal method the five minute journal
is its it's a journal that was created
by a reader of the 4-hour workweek
actually for those who have read the
book it was their muse so they're one of
their cashflow focused businesses in the
context of lifestyle design but you take
two and a half minutes or so in the
morning and then again at night and so
one is effectively a focusing and
planning exercise there's also a
gratitude component which I think is
very critical for those of us who are
driven type-a achievers it's very easy
to constantly be focused on the future
just to pause for a second I've heard
someone say that depression is an
obsession with the past and anxiety is
an obsession with the future well if you
look at achievers they tend to be very
future focused and as soon as they hit a
goal or I don't have time to celebrate
this small win this isn't good enough
bigger bigger better etc and that is a
pattern that can be very
self-destructive even if you rack up a
lot of wins at the same time so the
gratitude component is extremely
critical that takes about two and a half
minutes each day and it also helps to
identify your focal points or your
priorities so that when inevitably that
10% that's left of the monkey mind pops
up to like dance in front of you and
distract you from your objectives you
set out for the day you can return to
that and then at the end of the day it's
basically a performance review and I
find it incredibly helpful and a lot of
ROI for the time invested rule number 17
schedule your time large uninterrupted
blocks of time you have to schedule if
you are creator blocks of time that are
at least two to four hours or more
no Frankenstein monster of 20 minute
breaks and ten minute breaks combined
into three hours will have the value of
an uninterrupted block of three hours if
you are trying to make high-level
decisions focus on time-consuming
high-priority projects push something to
a next milestone as a maker creator we
all have the same 24 hours in the day
and if you're like I don't have time I
can't sleep I need to cut back on sleep
I need to do this I need to do that if
you don't have time you don't have
priorities that's it
rule number 18 get feedback it's are you
one of those entrepreneurs who likes to
launch very early with a product which
is not finished and get as much feedback
as you can or are you the are school is
more like you do it in secret and you
you test you the market research you do
everything in secret and you launch when
you consider it it's really good so I
think that you can do both actually so I
think that it's possible to get that
early feedback which is critical without
making it public in the sense that you
can work even with a small group of
friends which is what I did with the
book but also with some of the startups
that I'm working with I get feedback
from people who represent different
demographics then incorporate that into
the beta when you when you make it open
but I generally believe in in fast
sprints so let's just say two-week
development Sprint's and so that might
combine with agile development but due
to expense push something out get
feedback take a brief rest do another
sprint get a few features out wait get
feedback and Google also does this on a
fairly large scale so when they launch
Google News for example they were
wondering whether they should sort by
location or date and there were a few
other variables and they decided that
they would push it out and simply see
how many requests and complaints they
got related to each of those features
and almost no one asked for location
most of the mass for date so that's the
feature that they built into it in the
next iteration so I believe in in micro
testing
I'd say it's generally my approach rule
number 19 simplify keep things simple
and when you're looking for solutions to
try
to remove things first rather than to
add things this is a really really
critical principle and les can be no can
be more in this particular respect
especially for behavioral change this is
a sign that I have over one of my
doorways my house simplify and above
that I have a knife
why knife because when you make a
decision the word decision is related to
incision it means to cut off it means to
cut away other options and to commit and
to focus that's what I recommend all of
you do with whatever that skill is that
you have in your head still hopefully
perfection is achieved not when there's
nothing more to add but when there's
nothing more to take away
rule number 20 do AcroYoga let's uh
let's just go to this mat here and oh
wait we got to do it the right my Dutch
friends ability yeah this is so yeah at
the end then I lean Mac then we bring
the partner down so apparently the Dutch
acrobats get very upset if you don't do
that I've got to the part where I'm like
you know I've had enough with the Dutch
I love the kickboxing or anaesthetist
love you but from all the jujitsu I'm
just like flop okay if I've made a lot
of like I say enemies that doesn't
really happen in accra so I am standing
with my feet reasonably close to your
hips I want to be able to touch my
Flyers feet yeah my feet are turned out
just below the hip bones mmm
I am standing straight up it's almost as
if you've seen the UFC you're like open
guard on your back and this would be
where I try to punch you and then you
kick me in the face but that's not a
crow that's MMA all right and then flyer
fingers forward got it you got the
acronyms and everything just so people
you're hiding I learn I'm I'm a young
padawan just learning what I can hang it
and then so the most important thing is
that you understand when to be water and
when to be earth and what parts of your
body so I'm gonna be watery with my arms
and really sturdy with my legs so we'll
take a deep breath on the exhale I
receive with everything and then I push
up with the legs here a lot of times the
flyer will want to put the hands down
and practice their handstand training
that means their control fleek yeah see
fold their top on the top of their hands
down the floor so at this point those
people listening I am supported on
Jason's feet I'm completely upside down
basically in a L straddle position for
those of you who know anything about
gymnastics and so this is folded leaf
sometimes in hushed tones jokingly
referred to as leaf blower oh my god
I'm trying to help people the images
here so this is scarecrow scarecrow
basically what I do is a base is I try
to let your body unwind pattern so as I
balance and shake a lot of times our
mind is connected to muscle groups and
flexing them when they don't need to be
so the true therapist is gravity which
helps to let your spine hang like a
plumb line and and could we show for
instance let's see here
super yogi sure so it's a Tim likes
traction so what I can do is I can let
my legs come off my 90 degree his weight
will start falling back we'll take a
deep breath together on the exhale and
my legs go back and they resist with the
arms it's okay
mm-hm two more inhale exhale I'm pushing
the legs back and giving resistance they
got a little wrist traction right one
more time inhale and exhale
and then where I love to go is to open
up your triceps and your shoulders so
I'm gonna place my hands under his
elbows and he can bend the elbows and
the knees at the same rate I can bring
the elbows closer as I feel okay on your
shoulder ya don't need to be a little
careful on the left yes I had it
reconstructed but yeah this is Bill
spine and in general where the body can
be vulnerable in the flying is in the
shoulders and the lower back so
communication is is really important and
just listening to your body all good
it's all good sweet side bending is also
a thing that can really help the health
of lower back and what's different with
the therapeutic flying from yoga is your
body doesn't have to be engaged you're
not using your muscles as the flyer so
you don't have to work uphill basically
yah mahn yeah well so those are some
basics of therapeutic flying
rule number 21 out work everyone I think
what I could attribute my success is to
is more the fact that I was confident I
could train myself to absorb or tolerate
very high levels of pain to outwork
other people to win in sports like
wrestling which is all pain right and so
I chose arenas in which I felt like even
if I lacked the technical gifts even if
I lacked certain coaching advantages
that I could still win because I could
just out last other people and I enjoyed
being an instrument of competition how
much and I still do I mean I love
competing I just like I'm better in
competition than I am in rehearsal I
understand yeah it's like kind it's
really weird but that's just me I'd like
I feed off their rule number 22 learn
before you earn find a situation where
you can be in the room with masters of a
craft and that could just be deal making
it could be joining a small company say
a fewer than 50 people where you simply
get to observe one of the principles
negotiating in an industry that you
don't even care anything about right it
could be waste management and you want
to go into high tech but if you sit in a
room with someone who's an absolute pro
at crafting deals negotiating getting
passed know those skills and maybe those
relationships start to snowball all
right and this is what scott adams the
creator and Dilbert would call systems
thinking's instead of being wedded to
the outcome of a given job you are
accumulating skills and relationships
that transcend that job okay and if you
choose your environments well because as
I've said before and as people like drew
the CEO of Dropbox as a friend have said
you're the average of the five people
you associate with most all right so if
you take
just a few years have the patients a few
years to really develop core
competencies that allow you to craft
your own reality and life negotiation
deal-making getting past though etc
learning how to pitch how to get
someone's attention in 30 seconds so
that you can then create the desire and
ultimately ask for some type of action
once you develop those then you can
really just create the map for the next
decade in the next several decades so
that would be it it would be learned
before you earn and it's never too late
to do that so I don't care if you're
coming out of college coming at high
school 30 40 whatever it is systems
thinking focus on the skills and
relationships first and then you can
just create a blank check for how much
money you want to make if that is your
goal
rule number 23 develop habits and
routines
whether it's Jaco will Inc you mentioned
retired Navy SEAL commander used to be
in charge of all West Coast training for
the SEAL Teams which is intense highly
highly decorated whether it's Jocko
saying discipline equals freedom or you
look at say some of the writers or
musicians or directors or others in the
book across pretty much all of them you
find that they find freedom in
constraints so what does that mean
sounds kind of weird it also sounds very
sounds like an oxymoron lit and what I
mean by that is all of these people have
routines they have set recipes that they
repeat on a daily and weekly basis so
that they are not making a lot of
extraneous decisions about mundane
things and they also recognize that we
all have our less ourselves our impulses
I love chocolate croissants if there
were if I left my entire schedule to
whim I would just eat chocolate
croissants all day long I love them
they're incredible
and I still do have them once a week I
have my cheat day and I'm allowed to do
what I want so I let my monkey mind and
my lesser self just go nuts
but these people all have typically
these and these are folks we might be
inclined to think of as superheroes and
maybe Jacko's a superhero but the vast
majority have one or two strengths they
may not even be the best of the world
but one or two strengths they combine in
a really unique way and they build
habits around those strengths and then
they have a thousand other weaknesses
but the habits and routines are what
help them from going off the rails and
this is really encouraging this should
be really encouraging because the people
we see on magazine covers that we might
idolize and feel we could never possibly
emulate because they have it all figured
out
they have no insecurities they wake up
every morning and with a mental karate
chops they just master the day that's
not how it works I know these people
almost everyone in this book certainly
on the podcast had become friends with
hundreds of these people not true they
have tons of not everyone I don't speak
for everyone but tons of neuroses tons
of terrible self-defeating habits and
the safety that they create is habits
and routines that's why Jocko in part
says discipline equals freedom okay so
you have trouble waking up in the
morning no problem you want to stage
this is something Jacko does takes his
clothing prepares gets this sort of
coffee ready to brew clothing on the
floor for the workout right next to his
bed prepared the night before so there
are no decisions there are no
opportunities to make mistakes
between him opening his eyes and Jocko
working out and you find this across
everybody remember 24 learn how to make
decisions another would be and I don't
know if you've ever had any interaction
with Kyle Maynard Kyle maynard's
fascinating guy he's that he was born a
congenital quad amputee so he is his
arms and before the elbows and his legs
before the knees nonetheless he is in
the National Wrestling Hall of Fame like
collegiate wrestling and is the first
person to ever climb Mount Kilimanjaro
with
prosthetics so he military crawled the
entire mountains he's such a stud and he
was taught by a CEO at one point the
CEOs used this for hiring but you can
use it for anything
this particular CEO very successful
would have his current employees rank
prospective employees from one to ten
and that's not interesting by itself his
rule was you can't use seven so I wanted
a ranking from one to ten
you can't answer seven and what what
ends up being so beautiful about that
and leveraged is that seven is a safe
number it's kind of like the
non-offensive switzerland of answers
it's not committal it's not too bad so
you can wiggle out of it whereas if
you're choosing a six that's barely
passing that's not good if it's an eight
you're indicating you are pretty stoked
like you're vouching you forced them to
make a decision exactly so you can love
it one to ten no seven and so I've used
that and kylus used it for say
initiations right anything imitation to
conferences invitations to coffee
whatever it might be it's like decisions
in life decisions in life rule number
twenty-five overcome fears what you have
been doing hasn't been working so you
have to try to say all right well what
is something new a new way I can
approach it there's a lot of the parties
that involve alcohol
what if there's parties at locator
fitness and health and smoothies and
juicing you know and so you're excited
about it and you're like you're
convincing me I'm like yo I want to get
my green smoothie on what happened like
oh how do i how do I do that I mean what
was the worst thing that could have
happened if you actually went for it I
guess the worst thing will be just no
one shows up as I thought it might be
interesting to have her right now try a
coffee challenge
Halon the coffee challenge is where you
go up to some random person the guy in
there they don't know about it and you
ask for 10% off she's very timid she can
be extremely timid and shy why would I
ask for a discount coffee we have to
train her to get to the point where she
can walk through those irrational fears
and you start with silly things few
people ask for discounts on your classes
[Music]
that means you should yeah knock them
dead you'll do great all right
fear is a really interesting animal it's
something that we all face in different
ways I get one mocked a 10% off on there
you have to inoculate yourself that
melee against the fear of rejection
uncomfortable conversations asking for
things you think you might not deserve
but really need so like yeah sure what's
the special occasion okay
congratulations yeah thank you you can
really train for the big stuff that
you're afraid of by practicing with the
really little things rule number 26 love
yourself I realized I'd say two years
ago but especially in the last six
months very recent that and this is the
part that would make my Tim of five
years ago just Crane like vomit a little
in his own mouth much it is I'm not
gonna mince words
I still have trouble sayings like self
love is not an indulgence it's not a
nice to have it is a prerequisite even
if all you want to do is feel successful
and take care of the people you love the
most
to really take care of them you
have to as I've heard said put on your
oxygen mask first mm and if you don't do
that like you you are also shortchanging
your ability to care for other people
completely and that that's been a very
very much an hundred and eighty degree
about-face for me right because for a
long time I was like I don't need to
care for myself mmm
like that's the word keeps going back to
me which is self-indulgent like this is
self-indulgent mic who cares rule number
27 find the right mentors very
frequently will ask someone for instance
what advice would you give to a 30 year
old just getting started here in your
industry what is the best advice you
would give and just as important I think
you should ask what advice should that
person ignore or what is the worst
advice that you hear repeated often in
your industry what is the conventional
wisdom that you disagree with those type
of questions give you a not to do list
and it is what you don't do that
provides the space for what you can do
anyone who says you should do this the
way I did it without any caveats should
be maybe ignored
in many cases but certainly viewed with
suspicion the the type of mentors who
tend to be the most helpful or those who
don't necessarily give you an answer but
they give you a better way of finding
that answer I'm leaving my second job I
want to start my own company what should
I do and they say well I can't tell you
what you should do because I don't have
enough information which is a huge
credibility point in my mind that they
have the awareness to say that and they
said but if I were in your position
here's how I might think through it so
look for mentors who don't necessarily
give you answers but who walk you
through the process of how they might
think about making the proper decision
given all of your
and I think that's what in my experience
separates a mediocre or decent mentor
from a great mentor
rule number 28 push through failures I
like the idea of showing people both the
successes and the failures so they can
see net-net
that it's actually low risk if that
makes sense I guess like a mess like
that if you're if you're developing
skills and relationships and that's how
you choose your projects and you're not
trying to appeal to the entire world
you're trying to find your 1,000 true
fans who are just as crazy about cricket
protein or whatever it might be as you
are over time you will make mistakes you
will have what people perceive as
failures but over time you will win it's
just it's almost an inevitability and so
if I can showcase that for people or
they're like oh I saw Tim Ferriss
publicly faceplant when he did I a B and
C and television that didn't work out I
saw him tried this new thing with this
one book that didn't work out but still
like in between eeeh this huge success
and this huge success
rule number 29 defined things clearly
define risk you know this is an
important question because I realized
that a lot of the knots we tie ourselves
into and the a lot of the anxiety that
we feel is actually due to using words
that are not defined very well like
success I just wanna be successful well
you better have a very clear definition
on what that is if it's gonna be one of
your mind and your main obsessions young
lady or young man yeah happiness yep
that's a slippery one too and risk is
another one risk to me is the likelihood
of an irreversible negative outcome yes
that's it that's it so define that way
they're actually very few serious risks
and I choose to take very few serious
risks people might view me as a risk
taker I don't think myself that way at
all
rule number 30 meditate I get a lot of
questions about how to start meditating
keeping in mind that I had a very severe
allergy to the word and concept of
meditation for
a long time more than a decade and I've
only really consistently started
meditating and implemented meditating
for the last two to three years but this
is why I think meditation can be viewed
in a way as stoic training or in some
ways similar to CBT cognitive behavioral
therapy because the objective is to help
you to observe your state and your
thoughts so that you are less controlled
by them what does this mean I'll use an
analogy that I think was originally
shared with me by Andy Pritikin who is
the founder of something called
headspace which I'll talk about in a
second which is the difference in effect
being say standing out in the storm
getting pelted with rain and hail and
wind and stinging your eyes and so on
being soaking wet or standing inside
looking through the glass at the storm
the latter is meditation the way I've
put it before which is slightly
different it's the difference between
being in the washing machine or standing
outside looking into the washing machine
and when you have that somewhat detached
observer perspective you can just be
much calmer much more appreciative and
ultimately effective I do not think that
meditation causes you to lose your edge
this was a concern of mine and I think
it's a concern of a lot of type-a driven
people but even if it did cause you to
lose saying 10% who cares ultimately
you're trying to succeed and make more
money and do all these things build a
bigger business to improve the quality
of life for yourself or others and you
achieve that I think more directly in
many cases by even if you had to take
say a 10% haircut on your edge by
improving your present state awareness
and by much much more fifty two hundred
percent so let's jump into a couple of
options right so if you're not a dog
because dogs are always present there
then you need some human tools one
option and this is the way I started
very early on meditating was listening
to one song so find once
and it puts you into a good mood and in
the morning all you're gonna do is sit
comfortably so this could be sitting in
a chair feet on the floor just like this
hands in your lap you generally are
going to want some type of back support
you do not need a dog
chewing on a squeaky toy so I may
intervene
Molly come here I'll grab the freak out
or you can sit like this which is how I
tend to sit when I meditate so this is
not full Lotus this is half Lotus it's
not even half Lotus it's really just one
foot tucked into the crease of my calf
and thigh and then I'm going to kind of
pull the butt cheeks so that I have a
nice little seat here back flat and then
my hands are how they're gonna be in my
lap like so or I will actually post my
hands on my thighs like this which can
also help if you have a tendency of
slouching to keep your back straight
alright listen one song for me it was
we're gonna party like it's 1999 Prince
it's hard to be stressed out worrying
about things if you listen that song
trust me you can pick whatever poison
you like but this was shared with me by
Kamal raava Khan and he suggested listen
to one song doing nothing in particular
other than listening to the song and
breathing and that's three to four
minutes that's it so you could try that
in the morning
rule number 31 make your incentives
compelling if you have some degree of
intelligence or just slyness you can
always find a seemingly justifiable way
to put off doing what it is you should
be doing and as a writer I feel really
qualified to say this because most
writers I know will do anything to avoid
writing I mean it's like all the plants
die well I can't possibly sit down and
work on my new chapter if my environment
contains a dead plant I really need to
fix that Devin Flynn it's like oh my
shoes are dirty well I'm gonna need to
get my exercise later in the afternoon
and they need to be ready so that I'm
not distracted later so let me put off
writing and the writers will just do
anything to get out of writing
and that's human nature it's not because
writers are bad people it's not because
say somebody listening is a bad person
that they've maybe been a seminar junkie
instead of going back to the note book
they filled up and actually putting next
steps on their calendar it's human
nature but for me right now it's it's
about the work and holding myself
accountable and maybe surprisingly to
some people I am NOT a huge I don't have
a high degree of confidence in in
willpower or discipline I have a hiding
to hear that from someone like you I
have a high degree of confidence in
systems and accountability and loss
aversion that creates the illusion of
discipline and willpower right so you
could take somebody let's just say who's
always had trouble losing weight and I'm
like all right I'm gonna take
photographs too you really unflattering
first thing in the morning after you've
gone on a bender in your tighty whities
in your kitchen now I own those photos
all right and they also take 5% of your
income and if you don't lose 20 pounds
in the next eight weeks and keep it off
for six months not only am I gonna
release those photographs onto the
internet post them on Facebook
everywhere your friends family
colleagues will see them I'm also going
to donate five percent of your income to
an anti charity
you would rather nuke then give money to
and you will be on the public record as
having given five thousand dollars to
whatever it might be you know they what
who knows George W Bush Presidential
Library or the American Nazi Party it
doesn't really matter and not sure there
are charity but in regardless you get
the idea to an organization that you
would just be endlessly shamed to be
associated with unless you lose this
weight and I guarantee you with that
that why two people figure out the how
to yeah I mean that's pretty powerful
external motivators yeah and it doesn't
have to be that intense but I
see no reason to I see every reason to
make your incentives compelling and most
people don't need more willpower or
discipline they need better incentives
so that that's either a reward or it's
some type of punishment and the
punishment could be prepaying
for say a certain number of training
sessions with an athletic trainer they
are non recoupable mmhmm right maybe
that's enough for a lot of people it is
even if they make a lot of money for
some folks the idea of losing a few
hundred bucks right will drive them
insane so they will actually show up or
having someone like working out with a
friend who's gonna bust your balls
metaphorically speaking gender neutral
whatever if you don't show up to be
their workout partner maybe that's
enough to shame you or guilt you into
doing it great use it rule number 32
break your thinking patterns what if I
did the opposite for 48 hours this is a
question I asked myself and at my first
job out of college I was talking about
suffering and maybe my desk was in fire
exit
it was completely illegal you know slept
under the desk the whole nine yards and
don't regret a minute of it but I was a
Technical Sales guy outbound sales guys
we had inside sales outside sales and my
job was to close deals with CTOs and
CEOs for multi-million dollar data
storage systems at that point storage
area networks fibre channel and what I
realized at one point was that all of
the seasoned sales guys who were doing
far better than I was doing we're making
phone calls between nine and five those
were the office hours and I said well
I'm clearly not doing an effective job
mimicking them what if I did the
opposite for 48 hours it's a very
recoverable experiment if it doesn't
work then I can always go back to what I
was doing doing the opposite met making
my calls between let's just say 6:30 and
8:30 and then 5:30 to 7:00 7:30
and it was just a hypothesis maybe I can
get a hold of the people I need to get a
hold of more effectively when the
gatekeepers aren't there and that's
exactly what happened and I started
booking more meetings and closing more
deals than than the majority of the guys
in the company and it was just from
asking that question what if it did the
opposite for 48 hours and you can apply
that to many many things and some of the
others would be Bob this is one I asked
in 2004 yep if I had a gun against my
head and could only work two hours per
week what would I do
I I know it's impossible what would I do
and that type of ludicrous question was
necessary to break my thinking patterns
and test stress test my own assumptions
of what was possible and you find that
that is a learnable skill rule number 33
get outside
what would Tim tell his younger self if
he could go back and change anything
about the past or tweak it to making me
better is there anything that you would
do I think that I would probably go back
not to necessarily my childhood but go
back to when I was really cramming and
just working 24/7 mmm prior to writing
the 4-hour workweek after graduation and
I would mandate that I spend 30 minutes
a day outside barefoot on the grass just
during the air yes just Lao get outside
barefoot be grounded get out of rubber
soles spend a little bit of time outside
every day I think that would have I
think that we don't think that would
have sacrificed anything and it would
have improved my mental well-being and I
think just general quality of life
well would you still be taking phone
calls on the grass it doesn't matter
just a lease on the grass just get on
the grass I could have been working or
like I mean these days for instance in
San Francisco I'll batch people who've
read the 4-hour workweek know that I
like to batch similar tasks together
whenever possible and I will batch phone
calls in such a way that I can go for a
one to three hour walk through San
Francisco sure
you're making the phone calls and in if
you don't need a visual reference in
front of you yeah you might as well be
it walking outside getting some exercise
and I think walking is also very very
underrated we've made a lot of
evolutionary trade-offs to be able to
walk extraordinarily long distances yeah
even compared to other say grazing
mammals like we can go for a very long
time and that's why evolutionary design
for lack of a better word so I feel like
we should exploit that and utilize it I
like it what is it what do you feel when
you get a barefoot on the grass what
does that give you I think it's it it
what it does for me among other things
is there are there people who talk about
grounding effective getting out of
rubber soles that that I think is up for
debate
gyah the scientific basis for that but
it helps me to feel grounded in a more
perhaps metaphorical sense and that is
feeling connected to the earth not
disconnected as some type of robot who's
been programmed to reply to emails just
like getting outside and being like you
know IH er if I love to curse
sure but it's just like you know this
this whatever [ __ ] I happen to be
obsessing about like it really doesn't
matter I mean like a year or two from
now like if that guy who didn't reply to
my email and I feel slighted right
probably like who knows his grandmother
probably died get over it get over
yourself like at the end of the day it's
it's so trivial and for whatever reason
being in nature and having that that
connection with the rest of the world
and feeling not separate from it and
cloistered in some type of office is is
medicine as a medicinal effect for me
rule number 34 learn to say no there are
many people who think and I've certainly
thought at different points in my life
if I just do X or achieve Y my problems
these problems will all go away
and what you realize is as you continue
on this journey that is often meandering
called life you don't get rid of your
problems if you
achieve certain types of success you
just trade up so maybe you had like you
know the the corolla of problems then
you trade up and you've got like the use
mercedes of problems and you trade up
and you have whatever the porsche
problems the the magnitude and
complexity can can become really
challenging and the opportunities become
themselves problems in the sense that
and many people listening might say come
on give me a break like this is such a
the want occurs like 1% or woe-is-me
story but it's not and i'll tell you why
because thank you very much in in the
very very very beginning of your career
I do think yes as a default can be very
helpful but when I say the very very
beginning I mean literally maybe one to
two years out of college if you go to
college you don't have to go to college
but let's just from my personal
experience once you have an even a vague
glimmer of a notion of what you're
really good at versus what you're bad at
and once you have a semi-decent group of
friends and colleagues and co-workers
the birthday parties the going out for
drinks the conferences that may or may
not piss away three four days of your
life these start to appear and they are
the siren song and my experience that
the the when I've encountered stagnation
in my life or felt overwhelmed for the
most part
sometimes it's due to you know
catastrophe and huge problems but very
often it's because I've over committed
to the kind of sort of cool stuff and
then my calendar is so crowded you know
as Derek Siver's who's one of my
favorite entrepreneurs would say also
just an incredible sort of philosopher
king of
and a just eccentric guy in the best way
possible you know he would say that if
it's not a hell yes it's a no to achieve
there are really big good things you are
going to have to let a a lot of small
recoverable bad things happen
rule number 35 lower your standards what
I spoke to say Paulo Coelho who's sold
100 million plus copies The Alchemist
etc you talked to Rick Rubin this let me
give his example first when he has a
musician who's stuck great musician but
they've developed performance anxiety
about song writing for whatever reason
he will say do you think you could get
me one sentence or maybe two words that
you like by tomorrow that's it two words
can you do that for me and he gives them
a micro assignment best writing advice
that I probably ever received and I've
ever received a lot of good writing
advice but I didn't get myself really
wound up because I expect perfection to
flow from my fingertips like magic and
that never happens so then I beat the
hell out of myself and that makes me
less likely to put pen to paper in the
first place and I'll procrastinate which
is why if you write two crappy pages per
day you've won the day that's a
successful writing day and that does a
few things it helps you to maintain
enthusiasm because you're constantly
winning and of course on many days
you'll write more than - you'll get to -
then you go to five or to ten but if
you're on an off day great - crappy
pages even if you never use it it's a
successful day and that I think for
longer-term projects and an extended
creativity is really important but the
story that this writer told me with that
tip he said okay this is where this
comes from did you know that IBM when it
was the 800-pound gorilla it was an
undefeatable sales force do you know
what one of the rules was it's like no
he says what do you think their quotas
were and I was like well I'm sure the
quotas were really high because they
wanted to motivate their guys to get
after it you know their quotas were the
lowest in the end
Wow and the rationale was we don't want
our salespeople to be intimidated to
pick up the phone mm-hmm
we want them to feel like they're gonna
pass their quota quickly which they did
and then they shot well past it and
clobbered the competition so the the the
the counterintuitive pairing of low
expectations leading to higher
performance is really odd I think it's
also very context and role-specific but
if we're talking about creativity in
particular right so not necessarily work
out but the approach there number of
prolific writers who have said Neil
Strauss said this there's no such thing
as writer's block which drives me crazy
so Mike come on like you might be a
mutant like x-men of writing but for the
normal humans come on like give me a
break and he goes no no hear me out
number one he is a trained journalist
and journalists tend to have writing
block beaten out of them because their
boss is like oh you can't find the right
prose for your 500 word article Oh get
it in by 5 o'clock [ __ ] yeah and
they're just like oh oh wait this isn't
school and they're like yeah deadline
that's that's your incentive writer's
block my ass okay but he said and what
what they learn is he said there's no
such thing as writer's block he said
what that is is performance anxiety that
you've imposed on yourself because your
expectations are too high mmm it's like
just lower your standards lower your
standards till you get started renumber
36 practice stoicism stoicism I think is
the one of the best operating systems
for thriving and high stress
environments in affect the more you
schedule and practice suffering the less
unplanned suffering will disrupt your
life and so stoicism if we go back to
say Seneca Marcus Aurelius is really
very similar to Zen and in many many
ways but it is a practical set of
beliefs frameworks and exercises that
allow you to inoculate yourself against
fear of the unknown fear of worst-case
scenarios to become less emotionally
reactive which is by why stoicism and
certainly you can look at George
Washington
Thomas Jefferson at Seneca on his
bedside table I think Bill Clinton reads
meditations by Marcus Aurelius every
year but if you want to look at some
additional contemporary examples it's
been become hugely popular in Silicon
Valley it's become hugely popular in the
NFL including the the past of the Super
Bowl winners that's two Super Bowls
because it it teaches you how to view
obstacles as opportunities and how to
become less emotionally reactive so
you're effectively putting the Serenity
Prayer into practice where you are
learning to separate the things you can
control the things you cannot control
and to only focus on the former end to
develop the courage and the ability to
act
renumber 37 keep things simple many
things that involve some discomfort or
pain can be productive right but not all
things that are painful our first lead
to anything productive there and the and
you can just become a masochist without
realizing it that's what happened to me
and I also felt like I could grasp
complexity and juggle a lot more
effectively than other people so I was
drawn to complexity because I felt I
could win there I felt like it was a
there was a high barrier to entry
mmm that gave me a competitive advantage
then at some point especially in the
last year I realized I'm just fighting
an empty jacket here like who's my
competitor is this ridiculous like I'm
actually just fighting myself and what
might this look like if it were easy and
it started as a journaling exercise
which is one of the most common patterns
in all the interviews I've done and
travel mentors and tools Titans and the
podcast journaling meditation and
journaling are kind of the two partners
in a sense they work together really
well
they recur over and over again and says
journaling one morning on what might
this look like if it were easy well I've
done it for many many different things
but with respect to this book yeah
specifically go for that well I did it
for the podcast when I started the
podcast
I had to ensure that there was next to
no editing I'll do with my friends in
the beginning to make it less
intimidating
I would allow wine which didn't always
turn out very well it actually really
ended poorly in the first episode in
particular but if that's what you needed
to do that's why I need to do just to
just like get the lawnmower started I
needed to to to grease the skids and
make it as easy as possible and you can
always complicate it later but if you
start with the complex the likelihood of
quitting or abandoning it very quickly
is high rule number 38 have a strong why
what is the driver what's that thing
that makes you be so willing to suffer
it's the promise of that that crack hit
for me which is the aha moment in you or
in you and other people so it's both and
the reason that I gets it too high from
it is if I can crack the code in the
sense that I find something that saves
people hundreds of hours or myself
hundreds of hours in the learning curve
for a particular skill or a particular
type of recovery or fill in the blank
just an elegant or non-obvious solution
to a long-standing problem I'm like okay
I can't wait to see how people are going
to respond when I provide that to a
thousand people and I see for most of
them the vast would already just go oh
leave like if you take someone for
instance I didn't learn to swim until I
was in my 30s I think we may have talked
about this I grew up on Long Island but
I had this death I was deathly afraid of
drowning sensing near drowning incidents
and some lung issues and now at this
point I was taught by this gentleman
named Terry Laughlin something called
Total Immersion which I first learned
from a book which I was introduced to by
Chris Sacca as a billionaire investor in
this book oddly enough but you can take
someone which which I did with Terry at
one point for the Tim Ferriss experiment
the first TV show I did this mother of
two I think
who had never been able to swim couldn't
even put her head under water in the
pool comfortably and four days later
open water swimming 500 meters in the
ocean and like 40 foot deep water
freestyle and when you show someone that
an impossible like that is not only
possible but that they can crack it
really quickly
that's my drug of choice I just I just
get such a high out of it
rule number 39 put things in perspective
a lot of folks look at me and some
people assume that I am a risk taker
always loves risk he's loves taking no
risk no reward and all this
I am so focused on risk mitigation at
all times you know any to and because if
what I did in the height of everything
yeah yeah living it I decided to build a
client service business I don't really
know I get it but I think that's in part
because you and I have had so much
practice capping the downside and like
walking through that rehearsal like
alright can I can I actually stomach and
handle the worst case scenario if so
alright i'll count my downside and then
eventually the upside will take care of
itself and you know like you shared in
in the chart mentors this is another one
i think about a lot which is when you
feel overwhelmed or unfocused you know
what do you think what do you do or what
do you think about and your answer was
you know if you're going through
something very difficult you imagine
your family dying in a terrible accident
and it puts it in perspective it's like
there are problems that we put in
quotation marks and we make a big deal
out of on a day-to-day basis and then
there are tragedies and crises and real
dark real things that can happen and
when you put in perspective you're like
oh yeah like right whatever getting like
my coffee 20 minutes late is cold maybe
not a big deal like maybe that should
not occupy any of my mind big lost a
huge account yeah yeah and you know one
thing that came up again and again when
i was talking to these various mentors
in different fields is the idea that
sometime you sometimes you need life to
save you from what you want to give you
what you need
so sometimes losing that account i look
back five years later and you're like
best thing I never had the best rule
number 40 try TM I want to hear your
response to one of the questions that
you sent to all of us let's do it so in
the last five years what new belief
behavior or habit
has most improved your life so for
everybody watching when you get this
book this is one of the questions that
many of us quote-unquote mentors have
answered yeah I would say for me it is a
consistent morning practice before
taking my phone off of airplane mode of
sitting and doing a meditative practice
for say 20 minutes and it's stuck
initially by taking a transmittal
meditation class of perhaps three days
when I was go through a very very
difficult time and Chase Jarvis who's
awesome and I've hugely successful
commercial photographer he's worked at
every big brand you can imagine and is
also very good CEO both he and Rick
Rubin is like the most legendary music
producer of all time just look at his -
Scott discography it's insane it's like
Johnny Cash Eminem jay-z Metallica you
know the list is absurd it's like
everybody you've never heard of and he
also said to me at one point because I
was going through a really rough time
and I was very tightly wound he said
have you ever considered TM and I'm like
mantra like you pay them to give you a
mantra it's a cult like I don't want to
be part of a cult and on and on and on
and on they're like now it's actually
really secular and I know there's like a
little bit of weird stuff but you can
just ignore that it's like the first
hour of the talk just ignore it what do
you have to lose and I was going through
such a difficult period at one point I
said you know that's a good point
so I did it and that kick-started the
meditation and then I experimented with
other things like headspace which I have
no vested interest in so it's you start
with 10 minutes a day for 10 days as a
proof of concept and the way I'd
encourage people to think about
meditation because I can sound very
woowoo and I certainly was repelled by
it for a long time is you are sitting
down say on a couch to practice
observing your thoughts and feelings and
emotions for a very short period of time
so that for the rest of the day you are
less emotionally reactive
what this means is you are rehearsing
your a training it's like going to the
gym so let's say you're training for a
sport all right you're an athlete an X
you go to the gym to do squats to do
this this and this so that when you get
on the playing field you can perform
better it's exactly the same you're
rehearsing and training for your day and
then when you run into something that
normally would trigger you whether
that's a certain type of email whether
that's an employee who hasn't habit that
drives you insane or you being behind in
your schedule and then the line at
Starbucks is longer than you would like
whatever happens to be the things that
would normally cause you to get really
tightly wound or explode or berate
yourself or other people you will then
start to spot before you have the
reaction and then you say okay the half
a second of breathing let me choose my
response instead of being a hot held
hostage to these loops and triggers that
we all have so that has been enormous ly
enormous ly helpful for me
rule number 41 focus on one thing
there's a I want to say it might be a
philosophers paradox but I don't think
it is I think it's just parable about
burdens ass so burdens ass about a
donkey yeah it's about a donkey who has
thirsty and hungry and there's water on
one side a few feet away and hang on the
other and he can't decide whether to do
the hey first the hey first or the water
the hey or the water and he dies of
thirst at the end of it he couldn't do
them sequentially you can do almost
everything you want in life but you
can't do it at the same time and if you
can just dedicate yourself to one thing
for even a year and then the next thing
for a year you can do those 10 things
but if you try to do all 10 at once
you're gonna be burdens s you know
should I do this should I do this or
should I focus on this [ __ ] force on
this so don't be a donkey
rule number 42 conquer fear so when I
was interviewing Jamie Foxx for tools of
titans
asked him how he developed confidence in
his kids he's one of the most confident
human beings I've ever met and he said
that whenever they were facing fear were
afraid of something stressed about
something he would say what's on the
other side of fear he would ask them
that and then he pause and he'd say
nothing nothing's on the other side of
your meaning that if you dissect your
fears if you name them and study them
they lose their power and the way I
translate that is with something called
fear setting in my own life rather than
goal setting that's fine but you can't
be driving around with the emergency
brake on so fear settings very simple I
look at the I take a piece of paper I
divide it into three columns at the top
I put what I'm afraid of
and the decision whatever I think is
risky or scary first column all the
worst things that could happen in detail
the worst things that could happen
second column for each of those bullets
what I could do to minimize the
likelihood of them happening and then
last column for each bullet if they
happen how could I get back to where I
am now if you do this exercise what you
end up doing is completely disarming
your fears because you've made them very
very specific you've taken them from
hazy to extremely clear and that allows
you to take risks and do incredible
things simply because you've removed the
emergency braking rule number 43
practice renunciation I found out
recently that Elon Musk went I think was
in college thirty days on one dollar a
day
did he really to teach himself that he
could do it Kevin Kelley one of my I
would consider him a mentor certainly
he's in the book I mean my my vote or
one of my votes for the real world most
interesting man in the world
fascinating guy he's got an Amish beard
built his own house technology futurist
who can predict all sorts of crazy
things that are coming down the line
even though he never once already
dropped out of school his story is just
nuts and heaven also at periods of time
would go on extended backpacking trips
he still does mean he's got to be in the
70s now travels with his kids quite a
bit and his wife and he'll go say a week
of sleeping in his sleeping bag just
eating oatmeal and nothing else
that's it saw my tent oh yeah right yeah
I sleep in that time yeah and you do
that every once in a while I try to do
something like that at least a few days
a month I almost always fast at least
three days months contiguous days a
month which
you need to be careful with you can
yourself up so have someone qualified
supervisor for stuff like that but when
you practice the the removal of of wants
when you have a renunciation practice of
some type or an ascetic practice of
sometime cold exposure also one of my
favorites although it's it's not really
the same category you you begin to teach
yourself not or realize in some cases
not only can you survive say sleeping in
the tent or going a week just having
like instant coffee and oatmeal and a
sleeping bag but for anyone who's gone
from say the hustle-bustle grind grind
grind to like a seven to ten day hiking
trip how good do you feel after that you
don't just survive you feel so revived
from it renumber forty four take action
so Derek Siver's is this like programmer
monk philosopher-king startup
entrepreneur and said derek has as a
couple of one-liners that I think are
really fantastic one is if more
information were the answer we'd all be
billionaires with six-pack ABS that's a
good one yeah and you just just just
absorbing not even absorbing just
reading and watching and listening to
more isn't enough like you have to apply
it you have to use incentives you have
to have rewards and punishments set for
yourself so you actually get things done
timelines etc rule number 45 use
intuition I'm trying to increasingly use
intuition intuition helps me to identify
things that I would like to test even if
they seem ridiculous so for instance
every time I've had a roommate in a
foreign country where I'm using comic
books to learn a language I get
ridiculed every single time they're like
wham POW smash really like that's what
you're gonna and and then three months
later there are convert because they see
I'm studying dialogue that's why the
comic books work the same reason that
scripts if you can get translated
scripts for movies which you can very
easily we're
so well for language learning intuition
is oftentimes just a a proxy for
interest so if I'm really interested in
something that checks the box partially
of the stakes and incentives right
rule number 46 pause almost all of my
most if you were to look at it from a
professional standpoint like my most
incredibly critical professional
opportunities and decisions have come
from slack in the calendar all right so
there the the must do things that are
important like we talked about that for
instance some of these things that I put
on the calendar for the next month or
two but beyond that because that's the
most important thing beyond that after
something like this a book launch or a
TV show launch or whatever might be I
leave a lot of the calendar open because
I cannot whatever I might plan I assume
cannot take into account this the
incredible and fascinating things and
people that will come out of the
woodwork as a result of say mm-hm
I'll launch like this so I just create
the space for that all of my bests
investments if you look at like Twitter
Facebook Boober Alibaba all this stuff
they all came from gaps in the system
yeah not through some crazy grand design
yeah whiteboarding how this is gonna go
no no I mean if it's it's for me and I
had a conversation with Tim O'Reilly
recently on my podcast which was so much
fun for people who don't know him you
can check him out he's he's uh
considered or he's been nicknamed the
trend spotter in Silicon Valley a really
good guy and he spends a lot of time
just sitting in stillness and just
listening and that's either gonna make
some semblance of sense to be pull or
it's not I won't try really dig into but
through meditation and other things he's
for instance on his one habit that his
most positively impacted his life in the
last year so is on his morning runs he
goes running every morning he makes it a
point every morning he goes on a run to
stop and take a photograph of a flower
mm-hmm ya know
the example it's like stopping and
experiencing some stillness and then
he'll just pause for a second and then
continue on its run and I'm sure I think
I've spent so much time yelling at
myself internally for so much of my life
there was very little stillness and now
I'm taking time and look I still have my
monkey mind I still have both the
bounces around in my skull and when I
sit down and meditate for those people
who might be wondering like if I
meditate for 20 minutes I would say 19
minutes of that it's just like to-do
list horn stupid argument imaginary
hypothetical discussion I might have
it's just nonsense and then there are
like 30 seconds from like oh this is
possible like this this state of
stillness is actually possible however
brief and learning to instead of
constantly yelling at myself just like
pause rule number 47 use anger to fuel
you what makes you angry was one of the
key pieces of advice that I was given by
writer named Poe Bronson when I asked
him what do you do when you have
writer's block he said what makes you
angry we're just right that and that was
also the advice that I was given by
Whitney Cummings and a few other
stand-up comedians how do you develop
material what makes you angry right
about that so I think anger as opposed
to just labeling it a bad thing can be
very useful fuel so what makes you angry
and let's just say you're writing about
something that doesn't require or seem
to require anger well if you're if you
can't get started it doesn't matter so
write about something else write about
what makes you angry and either you'll
be able to sort of parry that into this
other subject when once you get going or
you'll end up writing something
completely different and lend up better
in the first place rule number 48
journal a five minute journal popped up
a lot and that is something takes five
minutes in the morning five minutes at
night
another one was morning pages so
everyone from say Brian Koppelman The
Illusionist billions an amazing
screenwriter and producer as well he's
given morning pages as just one instance
so three freehand pages I think he's
recommended to about a hundred people
ten have taken them up on it and
he said summer between seven and nine
have had multiple hit shows multiple hit
movies multiple hit books it's a really
impressive actress and this is a daily
exercise that you wake up before you get
your day going is it important that it's
in that window I would say it's
important that it's before you're in a
reactive mode so before you're dodging
bullets of text and email this is part
of a very typical morning routine for
these folks and for me now yeah where
I'll just I will do my meditation steep
some tea sit down with my tea in the
front and the five minute journal or
morning pages yeah and that sets the
stage if you win the morning you win the
day rule number 49 learn to say no ever
one of the best pieces of advice I ever
received related to negotiation was
super simple someone said to me he who
cares less wins if you have walkaway
power or the ability to just say no so
another based on that in part I also
developed a rule for myself which I
follow I have followed very very very
consistently which is if so if someone
tries to pressure to meet me to make a
decision quickly answer's no if you want
if you want a knee-jerk response if
someone's like that's closing tomorrow
or subscribe but I don't know like like
either yes or no now like I'm not gonna
leave until you say yes to X like then
the answer's no absolutely no mmm it's
like any on-the-spot decision that you
want me to make or forcing me to make
answer's no and there's tremendous power
in them and it's a muscle that you
strengthen as you practice it and you
realize like oh like the world didn't
end right and it's not just it's not
that you don't care like it's more that
you're not defined by the outcome or
you're not attached you don't have an
expectation around the outcome like you
know that you're good
outside of however this goes down yeah
and rule number 50 the last one before a
very special bonus clip is have fun all
right so Tim Ferriss here playing the
dry-ice that I received in my Omaha
Steaks box didn't know what to do so I
sent a tweet out to my readers in Rob
Knight told me to experiment as he did
it as a science teacher with
room temperature coins and dry ice so I
cut a groove into the ice with my
Kershaw Assist open knife and you can
see here so it's it's freezing cold be
careful you'll freeze these to your
fingers like I did a minute ago if I
take a warm coin I can press it listen
to this cold and then it stops I thought
it was air vibrations but I think has
something to do with the temperature so
let's try a different approach I have a
cup of reasonably warm water here ah
don't do that and then I'm going to grab
a piece of dry ice here oh this is not
as refined as mr. science you drop that
in then you have instant fog look at
that how cool is that
and if you look inside I'll try to show
you guys this all the boiling bubbles
are white which is pretty sweet so you
have instant fog machine in your house
and then what's really cool which I did
has a very interesting visual effect is
you slowly pour it out so watch this
it's not half as cool looking at it from
that perspective but it's pretty neat to
pour it out the sink you have all this
fog throughout the house that's my
indoor atrium over there I'll show you
that while we're doing this as you can
see I have more or less than rainforest
20 to 30 feet of plants in there so I
can oxygenate and that's the end of our
science show for this evening thanks
readers
we look ugly now I've got a special
bonus skip from Tim on how to look for
ease that I think you're gonna enjoy but
before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions let's go
from just watching a video to take an
action here we go question number one
what do you need to learn to say no to
number two who are three mentors that
you're going to commit to learning from
and number three how can you better
schedule your time for success I've
spent a lot of my life really angry and
using rage and anger a lot of it
directed at myself as a fuel for
becoming a competitor because the only
well the only way that I felt validated
or valuable was to win period that's it
I was an instrument for winning and
competing and I only felt good in in
relationship to other people by somehow
being able to tolerate more pain work
harder to be number one
and it was more a relief of not feeling
terrible about myself
for a fraction of a day then it was the
joy of winning if that makes sense
it totally and so for my whole life I've
been so completely brutal to myself and
I've realized through a number of
different means you know one of which
anybody can pick up which is actually a
book called radical acceptance by Tara
brach which terrible terrible title love
Tara brach but very very helpful
introduction to thinking about the
potential idea that if you want to
really help people or you want to really
love people you can't do it if you have
if you hate yourself you just cannot
fully do it you cannot I don't think
it's possible so the last few years have
been and especially the last one or two
years a process of asking different
questions and one of the questions
they're many different questions but one
of the most important which which is
right up front in this book and the
reason the book kind of exists in a way
is what what might this look like if it
were easy things are hard enough or they
can be and there's so much uncertainty
in the world that for type-a
personalities or people who've been
wounded and have become very highly
competitive as a result are highly
driven I'm hardly driven yeah right and
driven we usually use as a very
complimentary descriptor but you know
horse that's being whipped to run faster
until it dies on the track is also being
driven yes and that's not always a good
thing and very often a bad thing that
question what might this look like if it
were easy is a really deceptively
leveraged question because you start to
look for elegance and he is instead of
the path of complexity that allows you
to absorb and tolerate the most pain
which some people myself included for a
long time viewed as an indicator of
doing the right thing or and sometimes
for me of strength yeah yeah it's like
oh yeah no I can read line for longer
than all of you yep it's like wait a
second yeah wait what do we talk yes and
this is good yeah the saying like and
there don't get me wrong there there is
strength and there are advantages to
having endurance but only when you're
enduring things that are worth enduring
mm-hmm as opposed to just making your
life painful so long answer long
monologue but I do think it's very
important to talk about the darkness and
the failures and the hard times and when
I interview people I always try to bring
that out because it's so easy like you
said to listen to an interview or to see
someone on the cover of a magazine and
think to yourself wow I really wish I
could do something like that but I'm me
and they're them and they've got to
figure it out
yeah and they always wake up at 6:00 in
the morning with like a mental karate
chop to copy the day with no
insecurities
and that's just [ __ ] it's not true
and I can tell you with first-hand
knowledge knowing some of the most
impressive people I've ever come across
in the world who become my friends we
all have our demons so I want I make a
real conscious effort to talk about
those so that people can try to create a
safety net against self-destruction and
certainly at least self-flagellation and
a rating if you want Tim's best advice
from the 4-hour workweek check out the
video right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there
but most people and past self included
I've resigned themselves to nine to five
grind in exchange for sometimes although
increasingly less and less